a massive manhunt is underway this
morning for suspects in the killing of a
Maryland police officer the Baltimore
County officer was not been identified
was responding to reports of a
suspicious vehicle yesterday when police
say she was critically injured she later
died in the hospital the cause of her
death is unknown investigators recovered
a black Jeep at the scene that may be
owned by a suspect witnesses say it was
used to run over the officer police are
now reviewing footage from her body
camera death row inmate in California is
getting high-profile support for a new
round of DNA tests that could help
exonerate him Kevin Cooper was convicted
for the 1983 murders of four people
outside of Los Angeles he says he was
framed
senator Kamla Harris said in a statement
quote I hope the governor and the state
will allow for such testing in the case
in the case of Kevin Cooper Erin
Moriarty of 48 hours has covered this
case for nearly 20 years Erin good
morning I know this case well we began
investigating this story after I
received a letter from Kevin Cooper
himself back in 1999 he was convinced
them that DNA test would prove his
innocence but when the results came back
they were not what he had hoped for it
was called the chino hills' massacre on
june 4th 1983 Doug and Peggy Ryan both
41 were found in their home hacked to
death along with their 10 year old
daughter Jessica and a young neighbor 11
year old Christopher Hughes eight year
old Josh Ryan's throat was cut but
somehow he lived three weapons were used
and Josh Ryan initially told
investigators there were three attackers
my throat was slashed here and I got
stabbed here and hit by an axe here but
the multiple assailant 'end when
investigators discovered Kevin Cooper
next door he had been hiding out after
escaping from prison on a burglary
conviction and in February 1985 Cooper
was convicted of the murders all those
serious questions remain how did Cooper
managed to use three weapons at once
he's ambidextrous he could use either
hand he
fully well ambidextrous Cooper's
fingerprints were not found anywhere
just a single drop of blood that a state
expert said was Coopers but most
troubling is a revelation that there was
evidence pointing to another suspect and
at testimony at trial it was learned a
sheriff's deputy destroyed it and I look
down here was these coveralls and I
picked him up and as I picked him up the
more I picked him up then I saw the
blood when Dianna Roper now deceased
found bloody clothing belonging to her
boyfriend a man with a violent criminal
history she turned them in Floyd Tidwell
was the sheriff wouldn't you say that
taking in coveralls that appear to be
covered with blood not sending them to
lab and throwing them away before trial
would be highly unusual happen that did
happen very very big in the early 2000s
the state conducted DNA tests on
evidence from the case and the results
match Cooper does that make you feel
confident that Kevin Cooper was
definitely involved in this yeah
but not everyone agrees Cooper's
attorneys believe that new and advanced
DNA testing on existing evidence
including hair samples and blood could
support the theory that there were
multiple people involved in the murders
and there are many including a federal
appeals court judge who believed that
the evidence that was previously tested
back in 2002 could have been planted the
governor is reviewing Cooper's request
for additional DNA testing and I should
point out the defense will pay for it
the testing mm-hmm I this is a very
tough case yeah and so the story is far
from over
it definitely all right Thank You Aaron